I mean part of that long time scale
there's a sort of intergenerational
commitment commitment to the future when
you commit to this and there are a lot
of people that are involved that know
they may not live to see that goal so
it's almost like you're building a
cathedral or something you're in it
because of the goal and there's a story
in this there was one of the times when
New Horizons when a Muto mission before
it was even New Horizons
was on the line and there's the there
was a senior scientist named Don hyung
who was like a God in our field and he
got up at one of these meetings one of
these committee meetings where NASA was
battling Pluto versus other missions and
and there were people saying oh this is
too far in the future and all these
things you know it's not important and
this guy Don Hunton who is like this
real intimidating but awesome guy he got
up and said you know goddamnit I don't
expect to be alive when this mission
gets to Pluto but this is important
let's get on with it let's do it and
people like committing to saying it
doesn't matter if I get to do it we need
to do it you know that was a part of it